hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to a
special video edition of ask Evan
today's post is brought to you by
Express Canada they've just launched a
new exciting contest under address or
business Canada Facebook page where you
can win ten thousand dollars and
consultation with facebook but I'll talk
a little more about that at the end of
the video today I'm going to answer
questions from one of my readers Ahmed
was asked me what my favorite book is
for strategic vision
so I made specific question was Evan can
you help by recommending books to me
which talk about competitive
intelligence or strategic vision Thanks
your concern Ahmed so thanks for the
question Ahmed if you haven't already
seen my page of my favorite books you
should go check it out my favorite book
for strategic vision would be radicals
and visionaries by thadius Varro the
book highlights the stories and advice
from over 70 famous entrepreneurs I'm a
strong believer in modeling success so
whatever challenges you're facing right
now with your business there's a good
chance that at least one of these
entrepreneurs had to overcome it as well
here are three of my favorite profiles
that I hope you can learn from number
one Jeff Bezos from amazon com our
vision is to be the world's most
consumer centric company where customers
can come to find anything they want to
buy online if you're looking for a
visionary and someone who disrupted his
competition Jeff Bezos is a great person
to model at age 30 Bezos was already
senior vice president at a Wall Street
investment bank he was making a
six-figure salary and was on the fast
track to corporate success in 1994 he
saw that the internet was growing at two
thousand three hundred percent per month
and wanted to capitalize on it by
launching his own business he made a
list of 20 potential products to sell
and settled on books he realized that
physical books source could only carry a
limited amount of titles given him a
huge advantage online he launched
amazoncom in 1995 with over 1 million
titles and call it earth's biggest
bookstore today the company has over
thirty four billion dollars in sales
thanks in large part to bezos's
unrelenting vision to focus on customer
satisfaction he's constantly monitoring
trends and following his customers into
new markets which have fuelled the
company's growth
number two ray kroc from mcdonalds the
definition of salesmanship is the gentle
art of letting the customer have it your
way Ray Kroc was a milkshake machine
salesman and as he approached his 50th
birthday had a successful career in
sales by paying personal attention to
his clients when he met with the
McDonald brothers who seldom has
milkshake makers he was impressed with
how they ran the restaurant he crafted a
vision where they could go from a single
location into a national chain when they
told him that they weren't interested in
doing it themselves they sold their
business to crock and let him run with
it today McDonald's is the world's
largest fast food company with sales of
over twenty four billion dollars to
think that it all began with a single
restaurant location that wasn't even his
to start with is a testament to the
visionary qualities that crock possessed
number three william hewlett and david
packard what i'm most proud of is the
fact that we really create a way to work
with employees let them share in the
profits and still keep control of it
bill and Dave started their business
with five hundred and thirty-eight
dollars in a small garage behind
Packard's house they flipped the coin
whether the call to company
hewlett-packard or pocket hewlett as the
business grew they became known for the
sensitivity they showed towards the
people working for them HP became the
first company to offer flexible hours
and profit sharing they gave their staff
more autonomy and created open offices
to break down barriers between
management and employees their
philosophies became known as the HP way
and have been used as a model for
generations of company since today
hewlett-packard has revenues of over a
hundred and twenty six billion dollars
and Hewlett and Packard are considered
two of the most respected businessman in
the country it all started with five
hundred thirty-eight dollars a garage a
passion for tinkering with electronics
and a desire to build a company where
everyone could take pride in what they
were doing
so I hope that helps amen here's what
the book looks like if you want to go
check it out and find it in the book
store my thumb's a little bit dinged up
because I've read it so many times but
you'll find that those are just three of
the stories out of over 70 profiles of
famous entrepreneur they have in there
and you're bound to find a store in
there that will motivate you give you
ideas to grow your business and help you
get to that next step so I definitely
recommend going to pick it up now just a
minor this post is brought to you by
America's best canada i mention you as a
contest at the beginning of this video
they've launched new contents on their
amex for business canada facebook page
and i'll include the link below it's
called take off with american express
and they're looking for canadian company
to give ten thousand dollars in cash to
and a one-on-one personal consultation
with facebook so all you do is visit
their facebook page and let them know
where you'd like to take your business
and that enters you into the contest so
good luck if you guys liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
under the video and stay tuned for the
next episode
you